j'ai fait le saut normand brodeur chauve
sa maison au mazout depuis plus de 20
ans mais ces factures ont tout
simplement explosé depuis le début de
l'année c'est une augmentation de 88 ch
ou
à l'espace de deux mois c'est ce qui l'a
poussé à convertir son système de
chauffage vers l'électricité je tape en
amont plein puis j'ai pris une décision
rapidement le cas j'ai vu la dernière
facture j'ai
réagi on peut la démanteler en morceaux
et une fois qu'elle est démantelée on
peut l'enlever des lieux françois
lalonde s'est spécialisée dans la
conversion des systèmes de chauffage il
est débordé depuis le mois de janvier
cette année cette demande s'est
amplifiée à cause de la montre et la
montée assez prononcée des prix de
mazout mais la demande était déjà là
surtout depuis que québec annoncé son
intention d'éliminer ces systèmes de
chauffage dès 2024 leur installation ou
leur remplacement seront interdits on
prévoit dizaine d'années les systèmes de
chauffage au mazout
un peu comme le charbon des années 50
c'est après une décennie
c'est sûr que le marché russe de plus
jeunes on dit le mazout s'est aplatie
pareil ces chutes les actuellement on
vit une période comme les lois ne nous
favorisent peau mais il vaut toujours
une certaine demande le règlement mis en
place par québec a fait mal à
l'industrie du mazout mais luc bertrand
quatrième génération a travaillé dans le
milieu est persuadé que le prix finira
par redescendre les gens deviennent très
et moitié
souvent on fait dire chiant c'est rapide
aujourd'hui attendait parce que la
conversion vers un système électrique
coûte environ 8500 dollars les
subventions offertes par québec peuvent
aller jusqu'à 1200 75 dollars vous la fa
le verra aussi le verra joie pour moi
c'est pour un départ est un
investissement québec estime à 200 mille
le nombre de ménages qui utilisent un
système de chauffage au mazout ici qui
me permettra au canada montréal